[SPEAKER_00]: Early morning on the fifth of the well sun, Jude and Leslie are led up into the palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince Jean's palace into the west wing of the palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: A servant takes you into that study that you and Paul often speak in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, the servant says,
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince Rivero, here's Jude and a companion of his.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, you walk into the room and see Paul Rivero with a book in his hand, one that you know well, Absalon's Methods of Torture.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: What chapter's he in?
[SPEAKER_00]: Looks like he started at page 100.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's probably somewhere near the thumb screws.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, now the real question is, is he reading it for effect, like with us walking in the room, or is he... Do it in check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know me better.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do it in check.
[SPEAKER_01]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I also know myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm like, I would totally do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Plus five, eleven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you would totally do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would totally do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it depends on if he's like...
[SPEAKER_00]: But Paul Rivera does not seem to be that kind of a guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: When he reads a book, it's because he's actually interested in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he's got a lot of books to read.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've probably read this one three times, and you know that the effect is more important than the knowledge that it has in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the later chapters get much, much better.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do they, dude?
[SPEAKER_02]: Paul, I'd like to introduce you to Leslie.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie?
[SPEAKER_02]: Paul?
[SPEAKER_02]: I am Leslie.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie is the rather kind of eccentric.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's had a rough night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wonder why.
[SPEAKER_02]: The alchemist assistant.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, we were attacked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you happen to find any of the bodies?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got some things for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, well, sounds like you know more about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me ask you this, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let me just tell you, let me break it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I go walk up to my palace.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get my books.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I come back, and I'm talking to my boy, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I can see in the distance, just... And I'm standing there, and you know what?
[SPEAKER_01]: It happens again.
[SPEAKER_01]: And again.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's an alchemy show.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So then I'm thinking to myself, oh boy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I only left for 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was a little shocked too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so then I get there and then you got Scarlet of the Brotherhood walking around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, did you get some of them?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I got a lot of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, the book.
[SPEAKER_03]: Mr. Paul, it was much funner on the inside.
[SPEAKER_03]: What was it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I showed up to that alchemist shop, and not only is that thing burnt down, and then you guys escaped to the sewers it looked like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, blame Jude for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he knows.
[SPEAKER_02]: We were... Did you recover the old man's body?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean... Oh, I did grab the body, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe I did.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, because he was poisoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: You told me the name of it before he died, because I was trying to help him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I tell him the name?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't remember, because I didn't read the... Do an int check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do an int check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because he also... 16?
[SPEAKER_02]: He also told me what Paul needed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Remember that?
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically said...
[SPEAKER_00]: Gift of Insamiar.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he wasn't killed from the wound, it was strictly speaking the poison.
[SPEAKER_02]: We got him out of there, that's why I used the spells that I used.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the Gift of Insamiar
[SPEAKER_02]: It caused him to bleed black fluid out of his eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's where he got hit, quite honestly, is it took out one of his eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or scratched in the face.
[SPEAKER_00]: The wound was bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, his eye was poked out.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I meant, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it was definitely not that killed him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'm sure you stopped reading.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, and then he also had said what Paul needs.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said, I know what Paul needs.
[SPEAKER_02]: It sounded like it was for his face.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never seen Paul's face, but it sounds like that was what the reference was to.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was talking about the powder that he went to talk about.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you're talking about the anti-sahuagin powder?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So do I have enough knowledge to recreate that powder just from my previous conversation and that one with him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't suppose there was anything left of the inside of the shop?
[SPEAKER_01]: Real funny.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, he... Like a couple bottles and... No, no, well, okay, what I mean is how well did you search it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, he's an alchemist.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fire is a hazard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shit blown up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Didn't know what to look for and it was kind of unsafe to look there at the time, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'd like to go back there before maybe at first light, but before too much time goes by.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, we'll go back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_02]: I saw that you had guards there because, look, he should have a firebox, something magicked, who we just need to find it.
[SPEAKER_01]: These...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know why you're afraid of these Scarlet Brotherhood or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys are idiots.
[SPEAKER_01]: They've decided to post up right next to the building that they're burning down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's kind of a characteristic of pyromaniacs.
[SPEAKER_02]: They kind of like to watch it burn.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's very true, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm just letting you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Complete unprofessional.
[SPEAKER_01]: But are you sure?
[SPEAKER_01]: They're just strolling down the street like a wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: I killed two.
[SPEAKER_02]: How many bodies... Did you find other bodies besides...
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, actually, the two that I got would have washed out in the ocean probably by now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I found, I think, about maybe three to five bodies.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, just other Scarlet of the Brotherhoods.
[SPEAKER_01]: We killed two of them, three of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys apprehended?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have something?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I have, yes, we have one important of notice and then some other ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hence the book.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very pragmatically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: I wanted to walk in looking like I was...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you gotta know.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you had a chance to torture any of them yet?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or, you know, question any of them?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I had these other locals that I brought that I've investigated.
[SPEAKER_01]: Locals?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just messed out, loved up, delusional delinquents.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, anyways, I just set them back and they couldn't give me any of the knowledge or importance.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, that's all I've investigated.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you mean just some other, like, bystanders?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, bystanders that were in the building that the Scarlet of the Brotherhood were staying in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any of them females?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, of the Skrull Brotherhood?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, one of them is a female.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did she look particularly dangerous?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, and we got her.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd really like to talk to her.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, me too.
[SPEAKER_02]: I take it they're in the dungeons?
[SPEAKER_02]: Staying with the guys that we already have a good relationship with?
[SPEAKER_02]: The guards?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, my guards hurt.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, the ones that we worked with before?
[SPEAKER_02]: With the thief that we had captured, remember?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you mean Rodiger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I don't mean the thief.
[SPEAKER_02]: I meant, are they in that wing of the dungeon?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, Rodiger.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's best to have a working relationship with the same guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh wait, no, you're talking about different...
[SPEAKER_00]: The prisoners are in your dungeon, where the main jailer was.
[SPEAKER_01]: He also put five guys down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I put other people down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'm refreshed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, would you like to see...
[SPEAKER_02]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who is this guy?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's the assistant.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just told you, I am Leslie.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why do you...
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: The man of the myths.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why do you look like a shrimp?
[SPEAKER_00]: I own the world.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know the mindsets.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know what will happen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Dude, where did you get this guy?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a little traumatized.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was in the back room.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know the alchemist, he's a little weird too.
[SPEAKER_03]: I told you, Jude, I know everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why don't you come with us and you can see what the other- My mind is too big.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hate you, Jude, I hate you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't just be bringing everyone into my palace.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, technically, I'm in charge.
[SPEAKER_01]: You were a stretch, but this?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm in charge of teaching you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you stop?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just be normal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, clean him up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank God, he's ruining it.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, he's rough.
[SPEAKER_02]: We both came out of the sewage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, clearly.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, we are cleaned up because we cast Prestidigitation and that took care of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: We cast Prestidigitation.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you hear yourself?
[SPEAKER_03]: I wonder if Jerry the Frog was still okay in that sewage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, you need to be quiet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just be quiet.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not helping yourself.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm being Leslie, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: The man of the myths.
[SPEAKER_02]: The man of the what?
[SPEAKER_03]: What's the man of the- I know what color- I know what's your favorite color.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's my favorite color?
[SPEAKER_03]: Red.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Leslie, just stop.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just stop.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just stop all your head.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is Prince, like, he's a young... Whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whatever of the city, he's like...
[SPEAKER_01]: I could have you beheaded.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I haven't even, like, seen you with your mask off, bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: No one has!
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, well, you could be anybody.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that's what I've been called.
[SPEAKER_03]: Isn't that some Canadian guy?
Shhh.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's no Canada here in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, um, yeah, let's go, I mean, like, let's not waste any time.
[SPEAKER_01]: These dudes don't need to sleep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, don't worry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know what you need to know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or do you want me to, like, because I'm great at improv?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it was kind of getting interesting, I'll admit, but... Well, bring the book.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a rookie move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'll make them nervous.
[SPEAKER_01]: Trust me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, then let me get a different book.
[SPEAKER_01]: A book that's like... With pictures.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, a book with pictures, but also it's like... Well, that one's got pictures.
[SPEAKER_01]: That one's got pretty good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me get one that's torture for experienced torturers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, can I take that one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because that one's pretty good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to get some pizza?
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys are gonna go down, make your way down to the Dungeons.